hello everybody wait just a minute while
everybody's audio is getting connected
so nice to see everybody so bright and
early if you are in Hawaii it's bright
and early here in California Pacific
time and all along the Pacific coast it
is 8 A.M in the morning and we are ready
to go
with ask.live so thank you everybody for
joining us today my name is Rebecca
dukes and I will be your host for the
next two hours of this program where our
goal is to make sure that you are
getting empowering information that
allows you to be an authority on your
own health journey and part of that is
making sure that you have the
information that
has been tried and trued and researched
I don't know any man that has done more
research into
the body and what it actually needs
to be able to thrive
now he has figured out when something's
missing this happens so making sure that
your body gets all that it needs
so that you can
kind of choose the direction that your
body is creating cells in is so very
important and I'm excited that we're
able to offer this program to you
now I do have to let you know that the
statements that are made in this program
have not been evaluated by the Food and
Drug Administration the products
discussed are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease and
the information contained on this Zoom
is for informational purposes only if
you are pregnant nursing or taking
medication please consult your health
care professional before starting any
supplement program
so
oh are you guys ready
I'm ready
so we are joining each and every week by
an amazing doctor who has been
instrumental in suing that fine
Institute of the Federal Drug
Administration with nine victories now
these victories have led to the addition
of vital nutrients and the ability to
say
these are recommended and essential for
health
and ah it's just crazy I'm I'm and
forgive me I'm kind of over excited
because of the information that we
that I have learned that I'm able to
share with you that has changed my life
and the lives of so many that I know
that I just can't keep the excitement to
myself now folks
we bring good news if you have been told
that you have a genetic condition
well that genetic theory has been proven
to be false and it's been proven through
the science of epigenetics epigenetics
is a study of how your very own
behaviors
and the environment that you put around
yourself can affect the way that your
genes work
so with epigenetics you are an empowered
individual and have more control over
your health Journey than you think and
more control over
your journey then the medical industry
wants you to know that you have and we
are Guided by one of the founding
fathers of the science of epigenetics Dr
Joel Wallach now Dr Wallach because of
his findings and his research in 2011 he
received the cloth Schwartz
commemorative medal a lifetime
achievement on natural medicine and
philorotrophy from the United Nations
and
I guess those are two different Dr
Wallach are those two different two
different ones two different ones
because one of them was in 2011 and the
United Nations thing that was in 2015.
no no no the 2011 was the Klaus Schwartz
award yes okay the the one for the
United Nations was 2015.
that's what I just said perfect awesome
well Dr well like I know that you have
been studying and putting together some
information here for us today welcome to
ask doc live and I just want to remind
everybody that if you hear anything on
this program that Sparks your interest
in wanting to know more or wanting to
get on a program that is mentioned in
this show get back with the person that
invited you to this show
thank them for sharing this information
with you and ask them what their special
way of getting the products is so that
you too can enjoy a better health
Journey now on behalf of myself my
co-host John T mccallier Ruth Ellen
Sanchez Heather Bowen and Dr Judy
Reynolds and
alstocklive.com this program is being
brought to you so please make sure that
you have your chat on for those of you
who are here with us live on Zoom
because they're going to be sharing
information in the chat that will help
you find additional information or how
to spell something that Dr Wallach is
mentioning because
he does talk very fast
so he's going to talk slower today right
Doc and if you miss what he says the
replay will be on askdoc
live.com well Dr Wallach welcome to
askdoc live take it away
okay good morning and thank you so much
for the kind introduction welcome to the
team Welcome to our visitors
and um I want to start out by saying we
do have
a video okay the Doctor Joel Wallach
story
okay for kids sake
for kids sake you cannot forget that
tagline okay okay so it's the Dr Joel
Wallach story for kids sake okay so
that's available right
it's already been sent out to 50 000
people on Facebook correct
at least at least okay and so you really
really need to watch this because it
goes into the understanding of why we
are where we are and why we went there
um most people don't realize
how
um which I say how dangerous everything
was as we were going through all this
all the wars we fought I'm going to use
those words all the wars we fought would
potentially life-threatening situations
okay so there's very heavy duty stuff
and we're here now because we were able
to Prevail and so
um this
um is a great video half hour and it
talks about
the wars we went through to get to where
we're at and so and then we did it for
kids so I'm going to leave that up to
you you can contact Rebecca and the rest
of the team to get that video uh the Dr
Wallach story
for kids okay
all right well today I want to talk
about it's all in your head
okay you've heard me talk about and
mention this book many times of course
we also have a CD that Rebecca and I did
the same title it's the support of the
book it's kind of an update a one year
update there you go
a one-year update of the book as in the
CD
and the purpose of the CD was to give
you kind of a one-year synopsis of the
results of people using the information
on the book okay so I'm going to give
you a little bit of highlight here
um there's 37 different diseases that
are caused by osteoporosis of the skull
there's 37 different diseases that are
caused by osteoporosis of the skull
that's freaky when you think about it
okay so let's go through some of them
here let's turn out with the olfactory
nerve which is remember there's 12 pairs
of cranial nerves in a spinal cord that
all start in the brain and it leaves a
skull
olfactory nerve number one when the
skull squeezes the olfactory nerve you
lose your sense of smell people say you
know I I can't smell dinner cooking
anymore I I just I'm missing something I
don't know what it is it can you smell
it okay and so people lose their sense
of smell
and that olfactory nerve cranial nerve
number one gets squeezed
on the optic nerve number two cranial
nerve number two
um you get optic nerve atrophy o-n-a
optic nerve atrophy it also squeezes the
optic artery in the optic vein and you
get
um uh
it pressure goes up in your eye okay
um the you get macular regeneration uh
the inside lining the retina or the
where the optic nerve goes into the
eyeball gets degenerated okay because of
the lack of circulation all this and the
other
and uh it's one of those things where so
many things happen with that optic nerve
gets squeezed and then when you have any
oculomotor nerve
nerve number three okay cranial nerve
number three you get ptosis okay
p-t-o-s-i-s so when they put that line
in your eye the pupil is supposed to
constrict to protect the lining of your
eye from that light
uh it doesn't happen the the people will
not respond to the
um
to that light okay so that's
I'm going to put that on here okay
that's oculomotor nerve up that's
cranial nerve number three
uh cranial nerve number four the
trochlear nerve your double vision
um
yeah palsy of all kinds okay things
start you're fluttering and so forth get
pain above the eyebrows pain here kind
of a headache okay
that's a cranial nerve number four the
trochlear nerve the triniumal nerve is
the largest nerve of the cranial nerves
okay it's actually three nerves and
I'm glad I saved that piece of paper
okay
and so the cranium the cranial nerves
okay oh I apologize here
the cranial nerve trigental nerve
okay
it's uh
cranial nerve number five
there we go okay the three nerves I got
to read them so I don't get them wrong
okay the three nerves are the
um let's see here oh my gosh
um do you have that your access there
let's see uh ophthalmic nerve okay
which collects and forwards the uh nerve
symptoms or the nerve signals around
the nerve number two that's in there is
a maximum nerve that gives you sensory
stuff and motor stuff in your face and
your upper lip and your jaw and so forth
and the third nerve this part of the
cranial nerve trigental nerve
um is the mandibular okay which has to
do with your cheeks and your lower lip
and your jaw on your neck okay
so that kind of covers that and it's one
of those things where
um all this stuff you go to different
doctors right you go to different
doctors for those things and of course
you also start losing your you get
receding gums you have TMJ get the joint
of your jaw okay that joint you get
osteoporosis and you get arthritis in
that joint that's all part of that and
when you're a kid you know you go to an
orthodontist when you're say 10 12 years
old because your teeth are all turning
and loose and shifting around every
seeing gums because you already have
osteoporosis of the skull okay and then
let's see here the abducens nerve number
six cranial nerve number six
um
that one
there we go abduces herb number six
um
okay you get strabismus okay you have
all kinds of weird things happening uh
the vision your eyes turn inward
okay so your eyes are kind of focused on
your nose
and then facial nerve number seven
okay facial nerve number seven get
Bell's Palsy okay
um one side of your facial droop it
rarely happens both at the same time but
maybe a month later the other side will
droop also
um and when a baby is born with Herb's
palsy okay
um they get um they're paralyzed from
the neck down because babies can get
osteoporosis of the skulls the mother's
not getting all the nutrition as the
baby's developing okay so it's Earth
Paul's doing the baby's born and when
you get this palsy when you're older
it's called Bell's Palsy okay then
tinnitus okay happens
um when the
vestibulotrochlear nerve okay we're
talking about cranial nerve number eight
the auditory branch of that when it gets
squeeze you get tinnitus or ringing in
the ears
and then when the vestibular branch of
the eighth cranial nerve gets squeezed
you get dizziness Meniere's disease
wallets vertigo that kind of stuff and
it's really crazy okay and then you get
lots of pharyngeal nerve number nine
loss of the gag reflex
um let's see here you lose your sense of
taste you have difficulty in swallowing
your voice changes and that's the
glossopharyngeal nerve cranial nerve
number nine
foreign
ER number 10 the vagus nerve that's a
big one okay pretty I'll never remember
Tim when it gets squeezed
uh let's see here
um
you get COPD chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease you have gastroparesis
I mean we're talking terrible pain in
the stomach and doctors just know that
you have a a penetrating gastric ulcer
but it's really just a tense cranial
nerve being squeezed by your skull it's
called gastroparesis because it goes all
the way from your skull down into your
belly you have difficulty in swallowing
your voice changes and you also really
you know you know get into trouble with
those kinds of things
vagus nerve number 10
COPD chronic infected pulmonary disease
hiccups
because we're talking about the
diaphragm the lungs abnormal heart rate
it could be fast heart rate tachycardic
abuse level rate of bradycardia but the
one that really freaks everybody out is
afib atrial fibrillation because the
doctors say that's a deadly heart issue
and they anesthetize you cut you open
take your heart out
and use a hot Branding Iron all over
your heart looking for the place that's
making your heart beat you regularly and
really there's nothing wrong with your
heart it's not a heart issue it's
osteoporosis the skull squeezing the
tense cranial nerve okay the tenth
cranial nerve
okay
the vagus nerve then
let's see here the accessory nerve 11
okay we're talking about cranial nerve
number 11.
and that one loss of function of the
trapezius okay muscles of your neck and
your shoulders uh
sternocleidomoistoid muscles in your
neck and your face and so forth and so
it's like you had a stroke you're kind
of paralyzed from the shoulders up kind
of thing and then there's the hypoglyce
hypoglossal nerve okay which is of
cranial nerve
number 12 atrophy the tongue speech and
malfunction so if you have that one okay
and the ninth trailer being a squeeze
you're really in a mess when it comes to
communication and so on well
then you have the spinal cord now when
you're talking about the spinal cord
you're talking about a lot of stuff okay
again the book is it's all in your head
and a lot of these common diseases that
people get when you get osteoporosis
gold is on the or on the cover okay and
then of course a one year update on that
book is in this CD that Rebecca and I
did and the CD tells you what's going on
there what kind of great success we've
had in in repairing and treating those
things and getting rid of them as well
as some that are a little more difficult
okay we'll talk about that on the CD by
the same tile it's all in your head all
right now the baby's born with with um
the spinal cord being compressed by the
skull obviously approach to the skull
maybe it's more with it because it's not
an age I think it's nutritional
efficiency thing it's called herbs palsy
okay also
when you get atrophy of the muscles
south of your spinal cord or your where
it comes out of your skull is wallach's
fibrous dysplasia Wallace fibrous
dysplasia and of course you get frequent
nighttime urination I get people I had
one yesterday the lady said she gets up
every hour to urinate she urinates six
eight ten times a night and if it was a
man the doctor would think right away
it's a prostate issue but it's not a
prostate it's because women don't have
prostates okay it has to do with the
skull squeezing the
um spinal cord and the spinal cord is
telling urinary bladder to urinate
that's what that's what's happening
there and then let's see here uh
you get sciatica everything kind of
South you get scoliosis uh Ms multiple
sclerosis doctors which believe it's an
autoimmune disease no it's just a simple
cholesterol deficiency I'll repeat that
it's a cholesterol deficiency and then
you get guiambray syndrome which is Ms
in teenagers and it usually goes from
the neck down whereas Ms you get the
skull the brain and the the neck okay
and the spinal cord and then let's see
here there's a respiratory
issues COPD and just you know on and on
and on and on all these things
are caused by osteoporosis of the skull
and doctors will send you to their golf
buddies who who are specialists in all
these different diseases uh when really
it's all just caused by one thing
osteoporosis of the skull and there
again uh you take the approach of
getting rid of all the bad foods and
maximize absorption and then I like to
use a big hammer when you have obstacles
of skull it's one healthy brain and
heart pack per 100 pounds of body weight
it has 215 nutrients in it and the core
of course is still the 90th Century
nutrients the Healthy Start pack and
then I like to add per 100 pounds of
body weight one bottle a month of the
MSM if you weigh 150 pounds more I'd go
with two bottles of them as Simpson take
three three times a day and they're
designed to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a rotary bone makes
including the skull okay including the
skull and then
um I also want you to have the collagen
peptides which is collagen made from
fish poultry sheep and beef go ahead and
take a scoop of that in your morning
drink scoop of that your evening drink
and then
I like you to take synaptive or
synaptive I think I I thought I had a
bottle here
synaptive uh
oh I apologize I don't have one don't
worry about it DOC keep going okay but
synaptive take three of those twice a
day for 100 pounds of body weight
because it has three things in there
that your brain wants if your brain has
to have this those items in the
synaptics work and function properly and
within three to five days I mean you'll
notice a huge difference in two weeks
time you'll be a totally positive person
and then don't forget the vitamin D3 I
want you to take three of those twice a
day so you can absorb all those minerals
and put them in the right place in your
skull because most people who are adults
do not you know get in their swimming
suit in their bikinis and go sit out in
the sun for three hours especially women
they don't want the sun because their
skin gets wrinkly and burnt and all that
kind of stuff and so they stay in the
shade so they need to take vitamin D3 so
they can absorb these nutrients and put
them in the right place and all these
things these 37 different diseases go
away because they're not genetic they're
not autoimmune they're simple
nutritional deficiency diseases
okay and so you have to appreciate
plants make vitamins and minerals and
proteins and amino acids plants oh and
herbs plants do not make minerals plants
only need three minerals NPK nitrogen
phosphor potassium to grow and make
seeds for their next Generation we need
60. so nutritional minerals occur for
mammals including humans and elephants
and wombats and bears and lies and
tigers and that kind of stuff rabbits
these minerals occur in veins like gold
and silver they do not occur in a
uniform blank around the cross of the
earth so you can be eating the same
recipe that somebody three states away
or Three Counties away is eating and
they don't have any problems you've got
14 different diseases because you're
eating food you know grown in a place it
only has three nutrients and they're
living in a place where the food has
grown that has access to 37 nutrients
which is not quite 60 but it's better
than three okay so with all that said
I'm going to turn it back over to you
Rebecca
all right Dr Wallach thank you so much
for that information in regards to it's
all in your head folks
and
he has all of those cranial nerves
listed the 12 cranial nerves and many of
the diseases that he has found to be
associated with
osteoporosis of the skull
so this book is look is already in the
process of being updated and edited with
the next printing it's going to have the
additional
conditions that Dr Wallach has found to
be associated with osteoporosis of the
skull so you want to make sure that you
get this book and the CD it's all in
your head you can get it at
askdoclive.com there is a
menu option there sorry
um that has Dr wallach's books so go to
sstocklive.com and you'll be able to
find Dr wallach's most popular books
well Dr Wallach we have hands up already
but I want to remind everybody
that you can get the replay to this
program at asks.live.com at most
importantly if somebody invited you to
this program make sure that you get back
with them and say hey I plugged into a
stock live thank you so much for sharing
this information with me tell me more
doc yeah do we have the ability to show
that the Dr Wallace Dr Joel Wallach
story is sold for kids do we have the
ability to show that to our viewers we
do have the ability to show that to our
viewers and why don't we do that in the
second half of today's show yes
give me a minute to get it all set up
doc
all right nothing like being flexible
and let's go to Christy who has her hand
up Christy go ahead and unmute you are
on with Dr Wallach
hi Dr Wallach um I I thought maybe this
was the pet one and it may not be but I
don't know if I can ask a quick question
about a pet
um he is you've given me some things to
do I'm doing all the things you um asked
me to do he is a terrier shitzu beagle
mix long long body he's older he's 14
years old his health has improved but
he's I think got some kind of virus um
that I've been told by some medical
intuitive psychics and
um his breathing's been really hard and
I don't know if it's just allergies I
don't think it's the food I'm feeding
him I don't know what to do for it if
there's a natural antibiotic or what to
do okay stop there you just keep doing
all the things you're supposed to be
doing for all the physical stuff
in case it is a virus we do have the
colloidal silver oh great give him a
dropper full under his tongue three
times a day and before bedtime okay
loyal silver will kill viruses bacteria
fungus I didn't even think of that thank
you you perfect thank you so much okay
God bless all right God bless you too
all right thank you Christy so yeah and
our pets are part of the family
what was that Dr Wallach our pets are
part of the family so we got to take
care of them yes they are and just a
reminder thank you Christy for for
giving me the opportunity to remind
everybody that next week the first
Friday of each month we do ask vetlive
where you are welcome to bring all of
your pet questions to the number one
veterinarian that I know who's not just
a veterinarian but a pathologist that
has done work around the world it is it
432 different species Dr Wallach
um as if um let's see here uh 465. oh I
was cutting this short sorry about that
465 different species folks
so next Friday first Friday of the month
ask that line you are welcome to join us
with your pet questions and yes they are
part of the family
so if you are here live with us today
and you would like to ask Dr Wallach a
question go to that Zoom menu click on
reactions and find the option to raise
hand that raises your virtual hand if
you're here with us and you have your
camera on and you're going like this I
apologize I don't see everybody's camera
um so I don't see your physical hand up
so raise your virtual hand using that
Zoom menu now Dr Wallach I have a
question that is come in from Dave
through email
he says two surgeons said that I don't
need hip surgery the x-rays show that
there are good gaps between the hip and
the femur but I have continuous pain in
my top right thigh and the muscles day
and night I have been drinking chicken
broth daily with turmeric hyaluronic
acid to coat the hip joint
infrared light so he's doing lots of
different options here to try to help
himself
um but if he exercises a lot then he
needs to take over the counters every
two hours to help get him through the
day is there anything that you recommend
to eliminate the pain in his upper right
thigh so he is 54 years old and six foot
one at
195 pounds
okay well this could be a case of
osteoporosis skull squeezing the spinal
cord
okay and so he's getting all this
Downstream stuff that the typical
approach of treating it isn't working
because it's actually happening up here
okay and he's getting all those
Downstream stuff and so the question I
would ask him
um and he can you know send that in now
if he can or next week if he can okay is
how many times a night does he get up to
urinate
if he says None okay it might not be the
skull but if he says I get up three to
five times a night okay then it's the
skull squeeze in that spinal cord and
you know all those nerves going down to
all those places okay
um are being squeezed
and so that's why he's getting those
issues that aren't responding to his
typical approach to dealing with that
pain because it's happening Upstream
it's up here as opposed to down there
okay so putting on topical stuff for
instance putting on a pain killing cream
on that hip is not going to work because
it's happening up here okay so that's
one of the considerations so at his
weight he was a hundred and what 195 195
200 pounds he needs two healthy pain and
heart packs per month he may
uh-oh
hold on Doc
between bone makes it including the
skull including the skull and the
vertebrae and the hip and the pelvis all
that kind of stuff and then he needs the
collagen peptides which are collagen
from fish poultry sheep and beef a scuba
that was morning drinks whether it's
evening drink wouldn't hurt also to
throw in the Beyond osteofx I do that I
take um a scoop of that with my morning
drink and my evening drink also okay
Beyond Osteo FX
and then vitamin D3 two bottles of that
so per monthly take three at breakfast
for your dinner time most adults do not
you know get naked and sit out in the
sun for two hours a day like kids do and
so they don't get enough vitamin D3 even
if they live in some sunny island and
you know in the South Pacific and so
forth they don't get enough sunshine
and so let's go there and then of course
we do have topical uh pain relief from
our
CM cream and also from our hemp FX
division but then also don't forget the
anti-inflammatory BTT 2.0 tablets you
could take three of those twice a day
they're not a replacement for the BTT
2.0 powder which is
the essential nutrients 215 nutrients
but the
um the the the tablets are to support
maintenance repair okay by supporting
circulation reducing inflammation that
kind of stuff and
as opposed to the 90 essential nutrients
all right hey Dr Wallach
we've got some technical issues going on
so while I get these technical issues
fixed why don't we watch that video that
you wanted to watch
all right hold on everybody we're gonna
get this all set up so that you can
enjoy it as well I know Dr Wallach is
super excited about it and
I I think it turned out pretty well yeah
you have to watch it down to that last
couple of seconds because the biggest
message is in the last minute of this of
the video
all right
one moment while I get this all set up
okay can everybody see my screen
I can see alien oh hold on let's start
from the beginning
there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
if something is false he calls it out
even if it means
alienating the entire medical community
he doesn't care he cares about the truth
Marlon Perkins put my father on this
path early on that's ultimately what led
to my father making the discovery many
many years later of cystic fibrosis
I was excited to help kids with sister
roses
and they fired me
[Music]
he's never been tied to a certain set of
research or a food company or a drug
company or the dollar he's just been
committed to his heart and what he knew
they would actually follow us and hand
out petitions and they actually had
people arrested it was quite the fight
back in the early days he's not going to
be stopped by the FDA no one wants to
take on the FDA no one wants to go
through that battle I've seen my father
deal with a lot of blows that would
cause most people to just curl up in a
ball and quit I don't care if he gets
knocked down another 20 times he will
get up that 21st time
and give lectures all over the world
people every month come up to me and
tell me how I save their lives how the
information saved their mother how it
saved their kids you cannot pay for that
you cannot pay for it that's worth
everything
[Music]
wow dad 20 years 20 years could you
imagine that we'd be here tonight 20
years ago well I actually have a great
story about that but who knew who knew
who knew but here we are did you but no
honestly I mean can you give us a short
version did you really believe 20 years
ago when I came down in my Forerunner
with my sister my brother-in-law my two
weenie dogs and a baby that it would
lead to this
well I was asked that question
24 years ago 24 years ago how big do you
think you're going to get
I said well we want to get and take over
the biggest network marketing companies
in the world these people
laughs
because we needed to we needed to build
an army to get this information out just
to save kids that was the whole idea we
needed an army one little shark guy
couldn't do by himself so he needed an
army and it's time to call in the
calvary
and these people were all kind of Union
people and they fell on their back and
laughed and kicked in the air and
laughed and laughed and laughed you know
today these same people are saying
remember what you said
we believe you now
oh
so
over that 20 years over the last 20
years of youngevity
you know I was asked what things really
stand out as like just amazing moments
or accomplishments and things and you
know what what really stands out to me
is as a major accomplishment of this
company what sets this company apart
from other direct selling companies are
the FDA Health claim petitions and you
really drove those obviously with
Jonathan e-mort's help and and all of
that but I mean
as Michelle said in that video nobody
wants to to go up against the FDA and
you didn't bat an eye you didn't blink
why why was that important to get that
Health freedom information or that
health information out and maintain
Health freedom to you why was that so
important
well number one when you know how to
save kids with the discovery of the Z
like cystic fibrosis muscular dystrophy
these sort of things
and you get fired for it you know that
the system really isn't in it for the
truth
and so sometimes you just have to be
like David out of the Bible and just get
in there and go after the big boys no
matter what and that's what it was going
to require that's what we were going to
do
and if I may I'll throw this in when we
started after I got fired
um we started a little company and we're
doing great and we wanted to go public
because back then and
um Arthur Anderson big honor you know
auditing company
and we had him come in to audit us so we
could go public
this was just before this is like a
couple of months before we started
youngevity
and they fired me again because they
wanted my money
I was a distributor was very successful
distributor I was making a big six
figure income every month and so this
guy wanted my money and so they got me
fired and we had our first meeting in
Santa Cruz California just about six
months later
and it was all based on radio and
getting information out and people were
coming by the hundreds to come to this
meeting but nobody was coming in the
door because the Arthur Anderson
employees had hired three guys or all
over 250 pounds each
to turn people away and say the
meeting's been canceled
and so I had to say to the guy who was
hosting the meeting who other was Clint
Eastwood's driver
and um yeah Dio yeah I said dude we need
the Cavalry I can take one of those I
can't take three of them by myself
I said I want you to call 9-1-1 get five
squad cars here tell them there's going
to be a riot there's gonna be deaths
everywhere
we need five squad cars when men armed
to the teeth
and I just prayed that he remembered the
message
so I took on the guy in the middle who
was passing out the papers and we were
on the ground fighting these other two
are kicking me in the ribs broke all my
ribs on this side gave me a concussion
and here come the five squad cars thank
you Jesus and thank you Dio
oh
they cuffed them and to make a long
story short we sued him in federal court
shortly thereafter on the Rico laws
which are racketeering they were trying
to destroy us physically so they could
take over a company
and um they settled out of court the
federal court they settled
and that's the money we got to start
Young
[Applause]
so tell our audience a little bit about
how Dead Doctors Don't Lie came to be
did you did you sit down did you script
it out was it over a period of years how
did Dead Doctors Don't Lie how did how
did that come
okay well basically uh I was out giving
lectures and the sort of chapters for
the Cystic Fibrosis Foundation were
having me come and lecture locally
because they wanted to know what was
going on what years was this year oh it
had to be 1978 1960
oh yeah 1978 I was working for Emory
University in the Yorkies Primary Center
that's where I made the discovery and
they're the ones that fired me in
Atlanta Georgia
and um so getting these lectures in 2020
is following us so one of these days
you're going to see this if we actually
Steve finally tracked it down got the
video from the 2020 interviews I did
back in those days
and um
were
doing these things and
it became apparent
that we needed this when we needed the
army and that began to create things
that were sort of pre-made that
everybody needed and throw in a secret
sauce for the various diseases
and I know I'm getting off track here no
no that's okay but so it's 1978 let's
try to bring it to 1980 Something
well that that audio was recorded in
1993 yes now so but I know you had been
lecturing obviously all along up to that
point but okay so I actually had re you
know retired I was making good money I
retired and moved down to Houston Texas
where I met Milan huh
Sugarland Sugarland
and I kept going to the medical Library
and living with
um
let's see Jeremiah on the boat called
The Elixir we were living on this boat
down the lake and in Houston Texas and I
went in and you know it's Dawning on me
that people are already they always say
I got to ask my doctor you're dying
you're on 14 prescription medications I
got to ask my doctor about this
nutrition
and says well how good are doctors
really how good are they how long do
they live so while I was in the medical
school library there in Houston Texas
Texas Medical Center I just grabbed a
whole arm load of the journal American
Medical Association put on the table I
went to the obituary pages and I just
took the first 200 obituaries added up
the age and then divided by 200 I got 58
58 that's the average lifespan of
medical doctors America so I did it the
other way I took the other end and I
went 200 ended up and got 57.9
okay 58. and so I started making
photocopies of these obituaries the
doctors and handing them out at memes
look why are you going to these guys
look at that they're they're dying at
58.
and there was a football player who had
a kid with a mustard from
um Seattle Washington in Seattle
Seahawks he's playing for I was having a
meeting
down in Florida
and he flies all the way from Seattle
down to Florida and I'm handing out
these obituaries of doctors you know I
love the ones who are sports medicine
doctors don't have a heart attack while
they're doing a marathon at age 35
cardiologists dying of a heart attack
while they were in surgery and all those
kind of stuff and so handing these
obituaries out and this guy got him he's
big and we're in this Auditorium with
metal chairs and he started throwing
these metal chairs around
this big 300 pound football player kind
of like David rutz's size right and he's
their own stuff around and it's very
noisy and very loud
and uh everybody the 80 people were in
there huddling in the corner been fear
for their lives I said well can I help
you and he says I want to know why
you're handing out obituaries of doctors
and I'm here to find out how to save my
son with mustard history and I don't
know where it came from but out of my
mouth came only Dead Doctors Don't Lie
oh wow
so you went onto the radio
started the radio 23 years ago you
shared the Dead Doctors Don't Lie
lecture I would say or or message yeah
we do a monologue based on the newspaper
stories on health that day or that week
it was the complete strange quartered it
and made it into an audio cassette no
it's actually one of our Distributors
um let's see Barbara from Kansas City it
was actually recorded in Kansas City
yeah and
um
uh it was just my regular lecture
and uh
she was a horse woman she had all these
horses and
um one of the guys who worked for a
group was by the name they called it the
the
um committee for against medical fraud
and they they dogged me they followed me
all around of course
um
uh you know
you know what I'm talking about these
bad guys Jonathan John Renner and Victor
Herbert and Stephen Barrett and
everything and
um
Barbara she's a big woman she's six foot
three a couple hundred pounds and we're
up lecturing there where I actually made
made this recording
and he's handing out papers saying that
I'm a quack and don't listen to me and
everything
we're in the like the third floor
meeting room
and she picks him up by the belt by the
trough of the neck and throws him down
three flights of stairs
true story
and where's
where's uh Victor Herbert and John
Renner now let's see well John Renner is
dead Victor Herbert's dead Stephen
Barrett is in the basement of his house
and if he's still alive and his desk was
the old door
away
[Laughter]
whatever the questions are gonna go yeah
Jonathan they didn't tell me what they
were asking so
so
um
when you first discovered that case of
cystic fibrosis working for your keys in
the Reese's monkey I mean I I was a
child and grew up hearing about these
stories and read about them and that
Doctors Don't Lie from your perspective
I lived them as a teenager obviously and
it's just amazing you know uh just
reliving all of that stuff and then
Scott stalek was able to to get some of
that very very old uh video footage of
news stories and you can still find all
of this on you know Google the original
clippings or the newspaper articles and
things but as you said in that video and
you said here tonight they fired you for
going public with that information that
you believed it to be you didn't know
the term back then or it didn't exist
epigenetics but you you clearly
uh pointed out to everybody that you
believed it to be more than than
genetics not solely genetics that it was
uh nutritionally induced and you called
out the specific nutrients back then
which are true today obviously you still
hold to that uh that today so but they
fired you for that and I I know there
was a lot going on in your your family
life at that time growing up at that
time myself around then and obviously
but uh you kept going
as I said in that video you know you
you've taken some on some major
challenges that would cause most people
to just curl up in a ball and quit do
more than quit you would you know most
people would would absolutely quit but
you kept going
why
well again it was to save because you
know you have something that can save
kids
you just can't quit and of course I had
saved myself from horrible disease
Tourette syndrome when I was a kid I
started with the symptoms of Tourette
syndrome when i was four I was I was
disabled really disabled by the time I
was nine and my mom and dad had taken me
to 20 different doctors and the 20th one
um
Michelle always accuses me of going back
too far
when I was fired
when I was fired now I just to make sure
you know when I when I made this
discovery I knew that I had something
unusual I looked it up in human medicine
and cystic fibrosis and I got I got to
permission to do biopsies on the other
24 baby monkeys in that Colony that
didn't have any genetic relationship to
that one monkey they were just the only
genetic relationship they were all
monkeys but they weren't brothers and
sisters or cousins or anything like that
every one of them had a different mother
father they're all the same age and
they're raising these for NASA projects
or training these monkeys to do things
and they give them a pellet you know
when they do the right thing and they
send them off in the space
well I asked for permission to get a
biopsy of those other 24 monkeys and
guess what they all had cystic fibrosis
so I knew it was environmental well
fortunately they had saved the blood
from the from the adult monkeys
every month for six years and Frozen
just in case something like that had
happened
and they had saved the the
um blood every month for the baby
monkeys who are now six months old and
froze it and so I had I didn't have to
get a grant to to do those things they
had already done it for six years but
nobody had used the material so I went
back and all I had to do was look at it
and say well here's this one nutrient
this missing and I went back into the
animal industry and said oh look at that
the deficiency that nutrient causes
Cystic fibrosis in animals but they
didn't know that's what it was causing
animals because they were animal
pathologists
not people physiologists and so I took
it to the powers of be they sent it to
the highest experts in pathology around
the world and physical Brothers they all
agreed through the cystic fibrosis then
I told it was a monkey
they got excited at first oh we can do
laboratory animals and I said oh yeah
how many one I can make a thousand of
them
I said what
I said yeah it's not genetic this is
actually just a simple nutritional
deficiency even the genetic markers in
nutritional deficiency if I give the
nutrition nutrient intravenously the
genetic marker will go in 24 hours if I
give it to him orally the Jack markels
will go in two weeks and that's when
they fired me
and today the field of epigenetics is
the hottest research field there is yes
and what is epigenetics I mean besides
your best-selling book explained in
simple terms in 30 seconds or less what
is 30 seconds or less
okay well the medical profession has
thousands of failed medical theories
going back thousands and thousands of
years in the 20th century 21st century
is no different and whenever a doctor
doesn't know what you have or he's never
seen what you have he says it's genetic
or autoimmune or something like that he
just gives it a name that insurance
companies will pay for he says I don't
know insurance companies won't pay them
right so it's either genetic or
autoimmune well it turns out that your
genes DNA RNA and telomeres only control
XX females X Y males skin color hair
color and eye color other than that
genes don't do anything
they don't cause any disease badges
don't cause you see all the birth
defects are caused by nutritional
deficiencies in the embryo
and after 20 000 autopsies I had figured
that out that's my 1200 page book
and so
um when you know this when you know this
you know that you know it and I was
getting calls from the National
Health Federation which is Alternative
Health Group and they were the one that
introduced me to the problems that the
FDA did for people and so forth and they
had me come and lecture and tell my
story and that's when I met them I had
never heard of naturopathic doctors
that's when I met naturopathic doctors
there
um
and see
the uh it was in Chicago it was in
Chicago and uh it was one of those
things where I was introduced to A Whole
New Field because I was working in
hospitals and Research Laboratories
Clinton Miller yeah Clinton Miller no Dr
schroser also a little later at the same
time okay Dr schauser actually was a
weak first and he said I want you to
come and lecture at a bunch of Nobel
Prize winners with your stuff because he
believed me
Dr trouser believe me and so that was a
great vote of confidence from Dr
strausser one of my heroes now the the
selenium expert you got his PhD degree
showing that the selenium is an
essential nutrient
and then Clinton Miller
um from the National Health
Confederation Federation had me lectured
to them in Chicago
at the McCormick Center and that's the
first time I lectured to a group this
big and told my story and the
naturopathic staff came and said look we
want you to lecture at the nature pathic
School
right what are they I didn't know they
were and now I are one
laughs
so when
when you made that discovery of cystic
fibrosis in the monkey at your keys one
of the key nutrients you specifically
called out as one of the keys to this
was the selenium deficiency now this was
in 1977 I believe 1977 that's correct
they fired me in 78.
okay and so that's the way I remember it
so
um
but in 1977 1978
selenium was not a recognized essential
nutrient you knew it was essential but
the government the RDI RDA FDA did not
know or recognize selenium as a
essential nutrient
today it's an essential nutrient so your
work Dr schrauser's work other people's
work but your life's work contributed to
selenium being a recognized essential
nutrient
that's correct back then the medical
system believed that slim was one of the
worst toxins in the world they believe
it yet today yes you know a medical
doctor what about something oh you can't
have selenium but it's too toxic you get
everything you need from your food
that's like saying you don't need to put
oil in your car just put dirt from Texas
in your car there's bound to be some oil
in it dirt from Texas
bam you're dead
you knew I was gonna do that
laughs
okay so in the last
year and a half or so
you and Jonathan e more teamed up again
and went back to the FDA in regards to
taking them to school in regards to
selenium and this was in regards to
selenium being a required nutrient in
baby food sold in the United States it
was not a required nutrient to be put
into baby food
in the U.S so baby food sold on the
Shelf throughout the U.S did not contain
selenium yeah pet food did right dog
food dog food had patent baby food puppy
food puppy well the
canned milk for puppies oh yeah but dog
food too yes but uh it's all about the
dogs so
[Laughter]
but now the FDA recognized
the error other ways and they have
required that baby formula now contains
sold in the U.S now contains selenium
now
which goes back to your statement about
how important it is when you know that
information
in order to protect the the most
vulnerable the children the babies the
story gets better good okay
now somewhere I believe was 1989 Milan
and I went to China
to kishan province
and because we knew sleen deficiency was
was part of this of the syndrome of
cystic fibrosis cause
there's a disease called kishan disease
in kishan Province China which is
cardiomyopathy heart disease it's a
heart attack that athletes die from the
sudden heart death from athletes
and this province they have thousands
and thousands of kids die every month
from this because this selenium is not
in the soil there
and so I said you know I'm going to be
able to prove by going to Keyshawn
promise China Milan's family set all
this stuff they had connections
hospitals to give me the you know the
bodies and the slides and do the
chemistries and everything
so I want to do 2 000 autopsies
on these kids under the age of 10 that
died of kishan disease cardiac heart
disease because it's a saline deficiency
a slim deficiency I said you know if I'm
correct there's gonna be some of these
Chinese kids with cystic fibrosis if I
could just find 25 or 30 of them out of
2 000 because it's supposed to be a
genetic disease of Eastern Europeans not
of Asians if I could five if I could
find 25 kids these Chinese kids with
cystic fibrosis or died of Keisha's
disease heart disease a sleeve
deficiency I'll be able to make my point
well I failed I couldn't find 25 I found
595 out of 1700 fully 35 percent had
cystic fibrosis
100 had muscular dystrophy
and 200 under the age of three months
it all died of
crib death SIDS because SIDS is due to a
deficiency of selenium it's a
cardiopathy heart attack in these little
babies it's not getting tangled up in
their blankets it's not because they
suffocated sleeping on their bellies is
not because they were not sleeping in a
cardboard box
which is our newest Theory how dumb are
these people geez
okay so what this is going to do I hope
you appreciate because of Steve and and
you and Michelle and Richard Renton and
myself and jonathanie Moore and all the
stuff we did to get this into baby
formula we're going to eliminate SIDS
huh
we're going to eliminate cisier brosis
and mustard history now here's the the
next horror part of the story when we
realized that we could prove that this
slim deficiency also was the cause of
mustard history It's Not Unusual Calcium
deficiency causes 147 different diseases
so to have three or four or five
different diseases caused by
the slim division is Not Unusual and so
we gave the information after working
with some monstrously kids were able to
help them eliminate all their symptoms
give their body what it needed to
eliminate their symptoms effectively
they didn't have any more all the
genetic markers go away
we gave all this information to Jerry
Lewis he took it to the mustard District
foundation in 2011 and they fired Jerry
Lewis they stopped a Telethon and
somebody needs to go to jail
thank you
that's it that's it oh
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
hey
I thought that was pretty good it is
break time so let's go ahead and take a
quick break here on askdoc live
um everybody get up and stretch
make sure that you are staying limber
get those lymphatic fluids flowing and
hydrate don't forget to hydrate we will
be right back here on askdoc live for
those of you who are interested in that
video you can find it on Wellness
Publications YouTube page you will find
the Dr Joel Wallach story for kids sake
is the title of that segment
um
that Dr Wallach did and that was only
four years ago
so that program was recorded four years
ago and Dr Wallach is still alive and
well and kicking hard we will be right
back after this break
oh right what did you think of that
so I when I saw that I just thought that
that was an excellent clip
um showing Dr Wallach in explaining what
happened and what he did
to
protect the children
and unfortunately it took a lot of
babies dying in order for him to find
the information find the cause
on
what was going on
but he did he found it they fought and
like I said he's still kicking and
fighting
to make sure that the nutrients that we
need that our babies need from even
before their birth in the development
making sure that moms and dads before
conception are getting the nutrients
that they need and as people that are
watching this video and hearing this
information
I personally think that it's my duty to
make sure that it gets out to as many
people as possible
it's not about
making a sell folks
it's about giving people knowledge
empowering them with information that
will help them create a better stronger
Health Journey
Dr Wallach are you ready to keep going I
think we are
all right I think we got your audio
fixed too so okay good it's awesome so
Linda had a really good question and
this is going back to osteoporosis of
the school Dr Wallach her question is
can you please explain
how adding nutrients now the ones that
are missing will work to reduce the
pressure on the cranial nerves if the
skull is squeezing the nerves
okay that's a good question but you have
to appreciate that the skull like your
leg bones and your pelvis and your
vertebrae is dynamic your skull is not
poured concrete and it's that's the way
it is it kind of Ebbs and flows
depending on the nutrition and
circulation and other things going on
muscle pulls and so on and so I can take
somebody with TMJ which
is the joint of the jaw sticking onto
the skull
uh and you know the doctors want to do
surgery and all that kind of stuff and
put in false joints you know you give me
I say give me 90 days and I can rebuild
that and you won't need to go through
all that surgery and wrist infection
risk deaths from anesthesia and all that
kind of stuff
and the same way
um with people who have osteoporosis in
their bones and their legs oh my gosh
the doctor wants to give me a double hip
replacement she says there's you know
nothing they can do well give me 90 days
before you say that and we get them on
you know the healthy brain and hard pack
and we throw in the MSM and the collagen
peptides and the Beyond Osteo effects
and vitamin D3
and sometimes I'll even throw in the
Beyond as I say beyond osteos x and get
those nutrients to the bones and they
will rebuild themselves the good Lord
made us so that you get a fracture you
put the two pieces together the
fractural heel
um Butera muscle and you kind of put the
pieces together sew them together they
will regrow and heal well the same thing
is true with your skull uh you know
we're talking about kids who go to an
orthodontist you know when they're 12 15
18 years old and their teeth are tilting
and wallowing around and falling out and
they're getting receding gums because
the skull is shrinking okay because they
already have osteoporosis called it's
not an aging thing it's a nutritional
deficiency thing
and you give them the nutrients and
suddenly now the skull says whoa we're
ready to go back to work here and the
skull starts rebuilding itself and
tightens up around the teeth and they
can put braces on them so they can put
the teeth in the position where they
need to be and the skull will regrow
around those teeth sometimes it's too
late and the teeth will fall out and
they have to put in implants and that
kind of stuff but the implants stay in
there because the skull will grow around
the implant okay and the skull has a
tremendous capacity
to to rebuild itself because it has a
circulation coming up through the
carotid arteries and you give the body
what it needs to rebuild itself it will
do it we have the capacity to rebuild
and that's the whole story uh in the
book okay it's on your head and then uh
you know Rebecca Rebecca
um the whole idea here this was a
one-year follow-up on the date of
release of that book it's on your head
this is a one year follow-up of all
these thousands of people who used our
formulas to help repair the skull and
there's a lot of those testimonies in
here okay these stories are in there
where we showed that people was really
catastrophic
um
osteoporosis of the skull and dental
issues and receding gums and all that
kind of stuff voice changes and lack of
ability to taste and all balance and
getting up 10 times a night urinate that
all goes away when you rebuild a skull
because the skull normally is a quarter
of an inch thick
human skull but when you get
osteoporosis it gets to be half an inch
thick an inch thick two inches thick and
as it gets bigger on the outside it's
also filling in
the tunnels that the 12 pairs of cranial
nerves the spinal cord goes through so
they're squeezing those nerves you
rebuild the skull and those tunnels open
up again take the pressure of the nerves
and all the symptoms go away so that's
the basic principle
all right so you had mentioned that the
skull is shrinking where it's actually
getting thicker and shrinking incredible
pressure on everything on the inside
right it's shrinking on the inside and
it's shrinking in the tunnels where
those nerves go through those nerves
just don't flap around on there they're
going through specific tunnels in the
skull and those tunnels get smaller
because as a connective tissue gets put
in there because the skull doesn't have
enough minerals to maintain strength the
body keeps putting more and more
connective tissue in there but it does
as you say it does not only include
getting bigger on the outside but it
goes down on the inside too and closing
those and so it squeezes those nerves by
closing those tunnels at the nerves in
the spinal cord are going through but
they'll reopen again when you give this
skull what it needs to be normal
so let's talk a little bit more about
those nerves because I know that they
have a protective coating around them
call it a myelin sheath myelin yes
myelin with Y myelin that's what I said
thank you for correcting me but that's
what I said
um so share with us that myelin sheath
is made up of something that the medical
community wants to lower and eliminate
yes it's made out of cholesterol the
myelin the white matter of the brain
makes up 25 percent of the brain weight
makes up 25 percent of the spinal cord
weight
okay and cholesterol makes up 95 of
testosterone and 95 of estrogen nobody
should be taking statin drugs and
eliminating cholesterol cholesterol is
not what clogs your arteries it's oils
uh things like um salad dressings
cooking oils those are the things they
oxidize and turn into trans fat
cytopsychicamines are very inflammatory
and cause uh the clogging of the
arteries okay oh you know we take people
who have clogged arteries and they have
habit pressure and they're getting
dialysis six days a week they've been
doing that for 10 years because they run
dialysis for 25 years because they
didn't want to get a kidney transplant
we put them on our program the Hillary
and heart pack and the MSM and
collagen peptides and vitamin D3 and
then we throw in the ultimate daily
classic tablets which increase the
circulation as well as helps lower blood
pressure
and within two weeks time after 20 after
10 years of being on dialysis six days a
week okay they drop it down to three
days a week because they started
urinating again they haven't urinated in
10 years and then in tumor we should
totally off of dialysis and they're
urinating again to go back to normal
this is very simple stuff and so once
you you know have the key to the lock
you don't have to keep beating on the
lock with a hammer and you know and try
to get it to open and all that kind of
stuff and pull on it and yank on it and
turn it upside down you just put the key
in it opens the same way is true once
you know what the cause is and you deal
with the actual cause of these problems
the the negativity this pathology goes
away very quickly
all right and I love that Dr well like
we give the body what it needs and the
body
because it's continually generating
cells if you're giving it the raw
ingredients that it is starving for it's
going to start thriving
correct unity plus
so cells are getting stronger cells are
getting healthier and every single
square inch I'm trying to think of what
goes smaller than a square inch
is made up of cells
it's true you remove the things that are
causing the breakdown which you
mentioned oils bottled oils
olive oil cooking oil
vegetable oil salad dressing vegetable
oil is not our friend
okay that includes soybean oil corn oil
canola oil all of those oils have been
taken out of their natural state the
natural things that the Creator put in
there to preserve them and protect them
is no longer there
so it's oxidizing and when we put it in
our body it's causing like Dr Wallach
said those blockages those buildups it's
contaminating and putting toxins in our
body that our body does not want it does
not need it cannot process
so we need to be intentional and making
sure that we're giving the body what it
needs and keeping out the things that
are causing Havoc within us
right doc that's correct and you know
the people who
um have the shorter lifespans are the
ones that eat gluten you know like the
Italians and the Europeans and so forth
you know Spain and England and Ireland
and so forth
um uh you know they they lived me like
um
we we live to be I guess 75 and then
there's some places uh where for
instance
um uh people like uh the the Chinese
would be
um he 87
12 years of giving us yeah so I saw an
article the other day where 116 year old
Asian woman was being taken care of by
her 91 year old daughter
[Laughter]
that's where I want to be folks taking
care of my mom when we are both well
into our Beyond 100 yeah you know
pushing and Beyond a hundred so I I know
that it's possible and because of you I
can feel that it's possible for myself
as well
Dr Wallach we have some questions here
and Ellen wants to know
so she is 78 years old
are you writing I'm writing you ready
yep all right Ellen is 78 years old
five foot three
155 pounds
she just completed eight weeks on dice
uh doxycycline for treating Lyme disease
and she still has residual joint pain
what are your recommendations for her
okay family of course okay
50 uh 155 pounds right some close to
that okay so what I wanted to do is get
rid of all the bad foods no fried foods
no processed Meats no oils no glutens no
wheat bread no so sugar no drinks even
the diet one's got to go because carbon
neutralizes stomach acid so you cannot
efficiently absorb minerals and digest
food and then at that 155 pounds I
wanted to have two healthy brain and
heart packs a month two healthy pain and
heart pressure mother full dose
everything twice a day okay
I want to get two bottles a month of MSM
so you can take three at breakfast
entertainment they're designed to
support and promote maintenance repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between a vertebrae bone
makes your bone itself
and um then I also want her to take the
collagen peptides take a scoop without a
morning drink a school with their
evening drink I want her to take the
vitamin D3 through those twice as two
bottles a month and then I want her to
have the
um uh let's see here the ultimate daily
classic tablets so I get two bottles a
month that's like take three twice a day
it'll support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries in the brain the heart
the kidneys the lungs every place else
okay and it will also
support healthy blood pressure
and so and
um because she was treated for an
infectious slash inflammatory thing
Lyme's disease and she didn't get any
really significant results apparently
and we also want to do something
anti-inflammatory for her so it also
have her take three of the BTT 2.0
tablets okay that one bottle a month
will do because it's got a lot of
tablets in there okay so she can take
three twice a day and they're going to
very quickly within a day or two
significantly reduce or eliminate the
pain and swelling and inflammation and
of the BTT 2.0 tablets is to support the
immune system and so that's going to
help her with the quote Lyme's disease
unquote and so you just have to remember
that was a doctor's diagnosis
what is the percentage of
um
incorrect diagnosis in the medical
profession especially in older people
uh you know as we said they'll just give
it a name of something that the
insurance companies will pay for
and the insurance companies really never
go through and and try to
re-diagnose that disease is it really
Lyme's disease
or is it just osteoporosis okay so there
you go
all right thank you Dr Wallach and next
question that we have
Ruth Ellen keeps posting things so
quickly it went away
um so Willamina
is 58 years old
five foot nine
120 pounds
she wants to know what do you recommend
for post nasal drip and polyps now
polyps can be in different areas so it'd
be interesting to know where the polyps
are does that matter
huh
probably doesn't matter
okay she weighs a hundred and twenty
nine pounds at five foot nine
okay so
120 pounds 120 pounds 126 pounds
whatever it is and the polyps are in her
nose
in her nose Okay this can come just from
inflammation irritation okay and we have
to know what's going on uh in her life
is she eating gluten
okay does she have white hair which
tells us that white hair has nothing to
do with age it's a nutritional
deficiency okay and so
um
you know did they paint the inside of
her house she has all these chemicals in
the house and that's causing her to have
this post nasal drip okay
um does she have honestly approaches to
the skull a squeezing uh you know all
these sinuses and all that kind of stuff
and causing them to to drip mucus and so
on which is another possibility and so
we don't know any of that
we're just hearing what the doctor said
so she's got polyps
and she's got you know post nasal drip
correct yes okay so we want to do is get
rid of all the bad foods no fried foods
no process meet some oil so gluten as
you've heard this before
um absolutely uh no wheat by our oats I
would also throw in uh and additionally
you know wheat butter our oats and um uh
let's see here I got to get rid of
um let's see here
no nitrates no nitrine yeah all of those
processed foods
yep get rid of all them and so
um then we also want to do something
anti-inflammatory again three of those
BTT 2.0 tablets twice a day that's
anti-inflammatory and um uh also
um
relieve inflammation and pain
but also I wanted to have their
colloidal silver to take two droppers
full under her tongue three minutes for
each meal and two drivers pull under her
tongue through us for bedtime so if
there's a low-grade virus infection in
her nasal passages and up in her sinuses
and stuff like that the colloidal silver
will kill the virus and so let's go
there
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and just a reminder folks if you are
here because you were invited by
somebody specific get back with them and
let them know that you plugged in and
you were able to grab the show and gain
information and thank them for helping
you become more empowered of your own
health journey and they will have in
many cases because this is a business we
take out the big box
where we're putting profits and the
ability for us little people not even
those we do not have to have a degree or
multiple degrees like Dr Wallach has in
order to share this information with
people help people find a healthier
journey in life and also help us to
support our families that's one thing
that I love about this company about
this business where we're able to use
our passion and love for people to help
support our own families and our
communities so
Dr Wallach
you started this company how many years
ago
well it's got to be 32 years 32 years
even before it was
officially youngevity that's correct
it was originally called American
Longevity
and you had actual clinics
it's not just a vet and a pathologist
but you actually had clinics where you
saw human beings
yes because I was a naturopathic
physician by 1982.
that's right
your story your your little story in
that video
where you had never even heard of them
and then you be one
[Laughter]
or I you became one or whatever
said was super cute
minor folks if you're on with us live
and you have a question for Dr Wallach
find that raise hand option in the
reactions
um so that you can ask Dr Wallach a
question as well but whenever you don't
that gives me an amazing opportunity for
all of the ones that are coming in
through email
I want to throw one more thing out there
if I may go ahead and I knew I had
something but it finally popped into my
head you know you always hear me say no
fried foods no process means the oils no
gluten so wheat bread around oats do I
have to change that I apologize but I
have to change that there's no wheat
bother our oats are peanuts
okay because peanuts grow in the ground
tree nuts are quite safe but peanuts
um
are of the favorite food of aspergillus
which is a ground growing you know in
the soil uh fungus
and this this
um uh aspergillus
um fungus produces
um a toxin okay
okay it's called
um let's see here it's uh the the fungus
is um it's not that aflatoxin or however
you say yeah there you go amphotoxins
amphotoxin and amphotoxin causes liver
cancer and liver cancer is the third
leading cause of cancer death in America
so if you're eating peanuts with when
you're drinking beer your cause of liver
cancer wasn't the alcohol in the beer
it was the fact that that beer was made
out of wheat
and you were also eating peanuts along
with it's very common for people to eat
peanuts when they drink beer
so you got to get the peanuts out of
your life
no you know butter no peanut butter ice
cream
nothing do not give your kids peanuts or
peanut butter no no no they can have
cashews they can have walnuts they can
have pistachios they can have all those
kind of nuts all the tree nuts are quite
safe but the ones that grow on the
ground the peanuts
the the fungus
aspergillus
produces this toxin
um
amphotoxin which produces liver cancer
which is the third leading cause of
cancer death in America no wheat brother
our oats are peanuts all right and you
know peanut butter has been a staple for
so long
that we've got to just say no
one more just say no and I love the fact
that we now have so many different
options when it comes to Alternatives
we've got almond butter cashew butter
pistachio butter hazelnut butter
um sunflower butter tahini I mean all
these different other options that one
are more nutritious and two do not
include that liver causing
chemical
amphotoxin aplotoxin
um that is
third leading cause of death Okay the
third leading cause a cancer death in
America cancer death so that's that's
crazy so everybody
no more peanut butter
um yeah
Ruth Ellen has her hand up Ruth Ellen
Welcome To askdoc Live My Lovely co-host
oh um
hello Duncan hello everybody I'm so glad
that everybody could make it I have my
hand up for Scott s
so I'm going to Spotlight him and ask
him to a mute so that he can talk to Dr
Wallach
okay Scott
just give him a minute together you go
am I doing it right yes yes a little bit
sir okay how's that okay better
hi doctor uh I never really thought I'd
get a chance to talk to you uh I've been
listening to you for years on uh Coast
to Coast oh yeah
um
greatest
uh so 43 six foot one way 220
um
I've had uh numerous selfish used ever
since I was a kid uh
say my first major surgery I had a ACL
replacement
um
so now obviously
like you've been talking about doctors
or
trying to tell me I need a knee
replacement and
all that type of stuff but I've already
had
over 15 surgeries
um 55 surgeries
yeah I quit counting when I turned 40
because it was like starting to get
depressing okay now were all of these on
joints and bones and muscles and tendons
and ligaments
for the most part uh
I've had three colonoscopies because of
uh ulcerative colitis
um
which one time almost almost bled out
from it uh
my hemoglobin was down to
2.4 or something like that okay let me
ask you a quick question here how many
times a night do you wake up to go to
the bathroom and urinate
uh
uh quite a bit I'd say anywhere from
Dead four or five probably average
okay four to five or more
depends on uh
how how good is sleeping I I don't sleep
that well anyway so uh okay you know you
can give all kinds of excuses but I need
to know the number okay so if it says
four to five that's good okay
um yeah you shouldn't have any reason to
get up to your innate okay
um and so basically your skull you have
osteoporosis this girl do you have any
ringing in the ears do you have any
tinnitus or roaring or ringing or
buzzing in your ears
uh a little bit but uh the ENT I've been
to said is probably from I worked in an
industrial area for 20 years well he's
wrong he needs to have his license taken
away
you guys get process of the skull
tinnitus is a squeezing of the auditory
branch of the AIDS cranial nerve and
that urination multiple times in the
night is because the skull is squeezing
uh the spinal cord and the spinal cord
is telling your urinary bladder to
urinate now do you have any dizziness or
vertigo or balance problems
uh yeah as a matter of fact I do but
it's
I think due to a car accident I was in
about 11 months ago
did you not have any vertigo before then
no okay well have you ever heard of
whiplash
yeah I just had a pretty bad I fractured
my C1 and C2 and they had the
put it back together with some Hardware
uh-huh okay well here's your problem you
have osteoporosis of the skull if
osteoporosis all over so you got to
change your diet you got to get rid of
all the bad stuff no fried foods no
processed means no oils or glutens no
wheatenable rhinos no peanuts absolutely
none of that kind of stuff and then I
want you to have a big guy like you I
want you to have two healthy branded
heart packs per month two healthy brand
hard packs a month photos sure
everything twice a day once you get two
bottles a month of our MSM should take
three of breakfast three at lunch three
dinner time and they will support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae bone
microphone itself one scoop of the of
the collagen peptide powder in your
morning drink and evening drink I want
you to take our synaptic take three of
those twice a day that's going to help
your brain work better because it's
being squeezed Now by all these
um things going on on your skull
uh do you have any Dentures or implants
or anything like that or your teeth all
perfect
uh I've still got all my teeth a couple
fillings good I've got various rods and
pins and screws and stuff like that in
my body
okay one thing you might want to know is
I've had a kidney transplant okay
because you can't kidney fail yourself
one kidney or two kidneys
so both my kidneys failed
um
and then I had a
transplant from a live donor hey these
two ones these two ones working fine
no so my two were like shriveled up and
dead
and they just nothing third one in oh a
third transplant no they didn't take any
of my kidneys out they just added my
dad's oh okay
um
but they claim it was due to a
autoimmune deficiency called IGA
nephropathy I was diagnosed have you
ever heard have you ever heard hey hey
hey have you heard the science called
crapola
yeah okay that's crampola there are no
autoimmune diseases there are no
genetic diseases okay and the reason why
the implanted or transplanted kidney
isn't working for the same reason that
your own kidneys didn't work
okay I didn't mean to uh mislead you
might transplant kidney works just fine
it has since 2008 okay so what I want
you to do still do you have any habit
pressure on your medication for having
pressure
do I have what are you on medication for
high blood pressure
uh no no okay good do you have any sugar
problems
no okay all right well let's let's go
there just remember you're gonna stay
away from wheat Brown Ryan oats and
paint and peanuts and call us every two
weeks and give us a sort of a status
report because you'll be taking all
these nutrients you'll be taking 215
different nutrients
and you're getting rid of the bad stuff
to maximize absorption
of these nutrients so we want to hear
from you in two weeks and four weeks
since six weeks because you're gonna
have a great story okay and your dad's
kidneys can be very happy
okay
thanks doctor okay God bless you sir all
right Scott make sure you stay close
with your health coach she will be able
to guide you through this process
I dug it tell everyone quick more
question yeah go ahead surgery they're
trying to talk me into
um I broke my clavicle and shoulder and
I have this what they call uh thoracic
outlet syndrome it's cutting up the
circulation in my arm and stuff so we'll
stop what you're talking about reverse
okay stop there so once you get two
bottles a month of our ultimate daily
classic tablets take three twice a day
and support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries whether it's From
Plaque or pressure it'll get healthy
blood flow growing through growing
through those arteries and supporting
healthy blood pressure also now you have
to stay out of cars
that are taller than one story you have
to stay away from bicycles stay away
from steps because you're breaking every
bone in your body because you don't have
enough nutrition to maintain the
healthier bones
you've been a naughty boy you've been
eating gluten have you been eating
oatmeal for breakfast every morning
where are you getting your gluten uh uh
probably bread I guess I'm not a big
oatmeal I don't like oatmeal much uh
what do you eat for breakfast
Wheaties Breakfast of Champions egg
bacon and eggs
waffles pancakes uh not very often I'm
not too into sweet stuff like so even if
I have waffles I just put my fried eggs
on top of the waffle yeah we'll see I'm
not worried about the sweet stuff I'm
worried about the gluten in the waffle
gotcha
um because no matter what you take if
you're eating gluten at breakfast and
lunch and dinner that's why you're
breaking every bone in your body every
time you open your mouth you're breaking
another bone
so that's a clue I've made some uh
25 people
uh yeah we definitely need some more
time to talk okay so let's talk some
more in two weeks this will give you a
chance to start getting rid of all the
bad stuff I want to eat like an Asian
eat rice and sweet potatoes and
vegetables and fruit okay eat like an
Asian stay away from European Foods
wheat bun Orion oats peanuts stay away
from all that stuff
okay if you want to drink alcohol drink
wine was made from berries and and
grapes uh there are uh beers that are
made from rice from Asia and also from
Australia New Zealand but I don't drink
okay good that makes it easy okay talk
to you in two weeks sir okay thank you
all right thank you Scott
so Dr Wallach
one thing that I really I want to point
out is what we did as kids
affects where we are as adults also
but it even goes back farther than that
in my case where
go and buy all the things that I had
going on early in childhood I was born
with osteoporosis of the skull
oh yeah
doctor's nothing about this
doctors didn't know anything about it so
they didn't know to tell our parents so
it's not our parents fault but it's the
doctor's fault and whoever was training
them because they're the ones that were
telling us
and telling our parents what they should
and should be should not be doing and
Hell's Kitchen goes all the way back to
when minerals were stopped
exactly we know the exact moment the
minerals are stopped three o'clock in
the afternoon Monday September 4th 1882
on Pearl Street in New York City and the
bluff overlooking the construction
Brooklyn Bridge before that
the use of wood and coal for fuel goes
back thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of years now did
people just throw away the wood ashes
and the coal ashes no they put them in
their Garden as fertilizer because there
are 90 minerals and two or three percent
carbon
um Grandma used to put the wood ashes
into our food
for a kind of like a
an herb or something like that but
basically we were getting our minerals
from the wood ashes
okay we're getting our minerals in the
wood ashes
and um that's what was happening well
three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1802 in New York City
Thomas Edison pulled the switch on the
first commercial electric tanning plant
and 18 years later 1900
two-thirds of the American population
was obese and all the doctors are saying
look you got to stop eating animal fat
and eat more whole grains eat more whole
grains well that was wrong because we're
eating more wheat bread Orion oats and
everybody got worse okay and so it was
one of those things where the change
over from wood and coal is fuel to
electricity is what's caused all these
diseases we have since 1900 okay they're
not genetic and they're not autoimmune
doctors didn't know that so they said oh
it's got to be and the new darling of
the medical world back then in 1900s was
genetics so all these new diseases 45 50
60 of them which were just simple
nutritional deficient diseases they said
oh they're genetic diseases and sorry
you'll have to live with us for the rest
of your life and the doctors were happy
to just give drugs that relieve symptoms
but didn't get to the basic root cause
of the problem which was a nutritional
deficiencies the whole story
going from wood and coal the transition
over to electricity and what we had
before that transition to what we got
now is in this book this people they
call me after they read this book they
say you know Wallach they never taught
us this in school this is the craziest
thing we've ever heard but it makes
sense okay so everybody needs to read
There You Go everybody needs to read
that book
because it will help you make the right
decisions because you're saying well you
know Wallach is crazy you know taking
all these vitamins and minerals but how
many wood ashes are you eating Roy
okay if you're not eating wood ashes
every day now okay then you better be
taking the 90 essential nutrients
the doctor is one thing that I want to
point out here because you are you're
staying on top of things and it's
something as you discover things
changed things that even things that you
have have come in contact with it's like
and described 25 years ago have changed
now I have changed now and that one
thing that I've had a lot of questions
about in Hell's Kitchen is the use of
olive oil
you don't want olive oil right doc well
if you have a an olive tree
um
growing in your backyard and you pull
the olive off the tree and eat it that's
a good way to get olive oil but do not
buy olive oil in a bottle sitting on a
Shelf
um in a grocery store because it was
probably sitting in a barn for three
months at 100 degrees for three months
in the summertime okay getting oxidized
and so olive oil in a bottle or a can
Will clog your arteries
okay but if you just pick the olive off
the tree and eat it eat fresh olives
it's still on the stem that's fine
okay I'll you know themselves are not
bad but if you get the if you get the
olive oil that's been in a bottle or a
can for weeks or months or years then
you're in trouble
unless you have the expensive equipment
to press your own olive oil use butter
there you go so first there's food for
all vertebrates including human beings
is milk milk is the best food in the
world
and and butter includes vitamin A
vitamin A is essential for our eyesight
and making sure that we maintain Vision
so there's a lot of things a lot of
benefits to butter that it was demonized
for so long
well guess what folks
olive oil is not your friend and it is
mentioned in this book but replace it
with butter remember the average
lifespan of a medical doctor in America
is 58.
well yeah so
let's go to a question that Phil has Dr
Wallach in the comments here and he says
I had successful bladder cancer surgery
seven years ago however blood has
appeared again in my urine please give
me your recommendations Phil is 72 years
old
185 pounds at six foot three
okay
well here's where a non-radiation scan
you know a scan that doesn't use like
x-ray or anything like that uh find out
let's you know start there and find out
what's going on uh in the lining of the
urinary bladder you also need to see if
there's
um urinary bladder stones okay do you
have kidney stones causing the blood in
the urine these non-radiation scans will
tell you those bits of information
you can also take urine and do you know
have a laboratory do test to find out
all kinds of information
get a hair analysis get the book rare
earth wind cures and go to chapter 10
and 11 page 272 and get the hair sample
and it tells you how to collect the hair
sample how to box it or ship it don't
forget to put the Checker the money
order in there because the lab run the
test without the money and you'll find
out how many nutritional minerals you
have are they all low below the bottom
lines you're not absorbing because
you're eating gluten are they all over
the place like they're supposed to be
but some of them are very very low and
some may be very very high like too much
calcium no when you get calcium that's
very high almost always is because you
have osteoporosis and your parathyroid
glands are pulling calcium out of your
bones to try and maintain blood calcium
they're overdoing it and so your hair
analysis calcium goes up and the first
thing when a doctor looked oh my God you
have way too much uh you have way too
much calcium you know in your hair you
got to stop stop eating and stop taking
calcium no you need more calcium make
your
um
your body happy the calcium levels will
come down in your hair the next sample
three months later but also you have a
second chart in there uh it has to do
with the toxic minerals everybody's
afraid of toxic Metals lead and mercury
and uranium and other toxic minerals and
people say oh yeah I worked in factories
all my life I know I got all these toxic
minerals and blah blah blah blah I was
in the military and have all these toxic
minerals blah blah blah well here's a
way to find out okay and if you're doing
this if you're a youngevity associate
the cost of that hair analysis is tax
deductible because it's part of
your
information that you're going to give to
your potential customers your current
customers and all kind of stuff when
they see results of the hair analysis
and they get that book rarest random
cares and so your cost of the test is
tax deductible because it's part of the
advertising program for your youngin
business
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and again in the book rare
Earth's forbidden cures
chapter 10 and 11 10 and 11. so here it
is
Rare Earth forbidden cures
get this at assdoclive.com under the
topic Dr wallach's books
get your copy of it because this is
going to share with you all the minerals
it goes into how minerals affect the
body and it tells you how to read your
hair analysis including the instructions
on ordering your hair analysis
so
rare Earths forbidden cures a great book
I use it quite a bit
always referring to it when I'm doing a
review of a hair analysis with somebody
now Al has a question Dr Wallach
okay Al is 59 years old
he's
168 pounds
six foot three
he has been diagnosed with the
neurological disease possibly
Parkinson's or Progressive supranuclear
palsy
and the neurologist is not sure
what do you recommend Dr Wallach
okay
all right it could
Jamberry syndrome because they're all
kind of alike they all have Tremors and
they all have pain in the head and the
neck and the hands and so forth they all
have a remarkable Downstream problems
with movement and and so forth
um
and it's because when you get uh things
like Alzheimer's disease you get
Guillain-Barre syndrome you get things
like Ms you get Parkinson's disease this
is caused by demolinization okay the the
myelin and the brain and spinal cord go
away
and when they go away you can take a
scan a non-radiation scan you can see
that the brain is all shrunken up inside
the skull because the white matter of
the brain okay the cholesterol is made
out of cholesterol 25 of your brain
weight in your spinal cord weight is
cholesterol
and when it goes away because you're on
statin drugs and you're avoiding eating
eggs and other sources of cholesterol
your brain kind of shrinks your spinal
cord shrinks you get all these symptoms
Downstream
okay and this is where you have to
appreciate that um there's a lot of
misinformation out there when it comes
to nutrition and disease and nutrition
and symptoms
and nutrition and Longevity and so
um I urge everybody when you have those
kind of diseases get a hair analysis
okay this guy needs to get a hair
analysis
but in the meantime uh I would have them
take a three eggs twice a day with soft
yolk soft boiled soft poke soft soft
scramble and butter hard-boiled eggs
won't count and
the Fridays will cause cancer uh also
they need two healthy and heart packs
per month for those filling twice a day
two bottles a month of the MSM three of
breakfast free lunch or dinner time to
support and promote Mage repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between a vertebrae bone
makes bone itself including the skull
all right and the vertebrae and so on
and then I throw in the Beyond osteofx
throw in a scoop of that with the
morning breakfast just drink in the
evening drink don't forget vitamin D
three three of those twice a day then I
would also throw in the synaptive three
of those twice a day oh my gosh that's
two bottles a month and each one of
those bottles there's three different
sources of stuff that's required by the
the brain so that the myelin can be
protected so each brain cell can talk to
their neighbor
brain cells and get maximum benefit uh
we we get people who are really really
in trouble
and just in in weeks
you know they go from being totally
disabled to going out and playing tennis
and all this kind of stuff it's just
totally remarkable when you rebuild the
myelin in the brain and the spinal cord
so that's where I'm I'm betting on this
one
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and fortunately Al added that he does
not have the trimmers so that's that's a
blessing that he has not been
experiencing the Tremors but the fact
that they don't know what it is Dr
Wallach
it goes right back to nutritional
deficiencies
if they don't know what it is it's a
nutritional deficiency
yes I agree well let's see if we have
any more I don't I think I don't think I
missed any more comments there but I do
have some emails that have come in and
Peach says that he has been having heart
issues for a few years and he was
hospitalized on emergency basis two
years ago he had the ablation for uh
um he said water but it's afib and put
on numerous meds he did stop the meds
about a year ago and primarily went to a
Mediterranean diet which for those of
you who are not familiar with the
Mediterranean diet it is a lot of
vegetables But it includes a lot of
olive oil we don't want Olive gluten and
gluten and gluten
um and then he's the last four months
he's gone to a paleo diet
so the family stresses that it seems to
have brought on a rapid heartbeat high
blood pressure
how she processes the skull
all right and he lives on a ranch
um he works hard he gets lots of
exercise
well that'll kill you if you don't have
the nutrients
so let's talk about that Dr after a
while like okay
okay he needs to get this book he needs
to get this CD all right and then uh
none of the bad foods no fried foods no
processed me some oils or gluten so we
burn around notes and no peanuts right
uh absolutely uh no uh said no oils uh
and then absolutely no sugar and no
carbonator drinks even the diet one's
got to go well we have a wonderful
carburetor drink it's called rebound we
have the canister we have the box with
the sticks in it which powders and don't
have any um don't have any carbonation
in it but I like to drink the liquid so
I take the chemistry I drink the the
cans and I pop the tops during the day
and put them in the refrigerator I'll
drink one at breakfast in the morning
I'll drink the other one at lunch or
after lunch at like three o'clock in the
afternoon or something like that
but they're flat because there's no
bubbly left in it because they off gas
the bubbly all night in a refrigerator
so that you're not getting the
negativity of the
um the carbonation and so if you don't
want to mess with that just use the you
just use a canister or use the box with
a 30 sticks in it okay there's no
carbonation and the sticks are the
canister powder
and then
um
uh the need to again stay away from all
the bad stuff take the 90 essential
nutrients which is the healthy brain and
heart pack if finances are not an issue
um if you're excuse me finances are an
issue they can go with a Healthy Start
pack which is a 90 essential nutrients
if finances are not an issue go with a
healthy brain and heart pack okay which
is a little more expensive but you get
215 nutrients instead of just 90 but the
90 are in there okay and you know we
take people they're bald you know for 40
years and in three months time their
hair is grown back we take people who
have every kind of disease you can think
of I mean they're really disabled you
know just like we're just talking to
this young fella here earlier it's had
over 50 fractures
come on this is this is not right the
the doctor's still letting this guy run
around he has 50 fractures he steps off
a step and fractures his hip or
something like that there's something
really basically wrong there he's eating
gluten he's not taking all the 90
essential nutrients and so this doctor
is sending his kids through college
being paid for by this guy's fractures
okay and so this is absolutely what you
know it's insane for this for the
patient but it's Criminal on behalf of
the doctor
well and I want to point out that
osteoporosis of the skull which includes
you know the the brittleness of the
bones but it also because those nerves
are being pinched causing issues with
the eyes causing issues with the the
brain causing issues with peripheral
neuropathies and the heart has tingling
the heart with rapid heart rate
um or even skipping
afib all of these different conditions
associated with those nerves because
those nerves attach to different points
of our body
causing what's called referred reaction
whether it's referred pain referred at
reaction with tremors numbness tingling
go ahead here's where doctors make their
mistakes they believe that all these
brain nerves are just to to register
pain
didn't realize they have all these
multiple functions for each of those 12
pairs of cranial nerves in the spinal
cords 37 different diseases caused by
osteoporosis of the skull and I bet you
this guy who had these 50 fractures he's
probably got all 37.
it's very very possible Dr Wallach we're
coming up to the top of the hour in fact
we're oh we're there but I have a really
quick
um question kind of uh
I don't know what you would say but when
you start taking nutrients your body's
going to go through a detoxification
stage right
sometimes
and as your body is getting rid of like
gluten and adding the nutrients there's
going to be color changes in your stool
and in your urine that's correct
so I know that there are some people
they'll take the like one of our
digestive support AIDS the microbiome
will change the color of your poop
just just saying
um so it's not necessarily because it's
dark and does not necessarily mean that
there's blood in the poop or anything
like that which many people say go ahead
doc I'm gonna say quickly here because
time's Beyond us now
um quickly basically what they need to
do is take a sample of their
uh ugly bowel movement and take it to a
veterinarian and tell them it's his
dog's poop
and have it tested for parasites and
blood and all that kind of stuff it'll
cost you eight bucks
okay instead of 100 visit and all these
tests and x-rays okay and then also
um they need to do the same thing with
the urine they can get go to the
pharmacy without a prescription get the
test strips for the urine to see if you
have blood sugar in there uh okay if you
have sugar in your urine uh do you have
Pro how much proteins in your urine and
this is easy stuff
I mean if you can only read third grade
reading level you can do these things
okay this is not difficult and you don't
need a prescription from your doctor to
get these test strips from the pharmacy
okay yes okay and Nancy brought up a
really good point in the the chat here
that beats will turn your stool and your
urine red
and even cause
like the fluids around it to to look
like it's possibly blood so there's a
lot of different things folks that can
react with our bodies
that can be misinterpreted but like doc
said don't guess
it is a whole lot cheaper to go through
a vet
than than going to your primary care
physician
um that will be more accurate too and
they might even be more accurate there
you go well on behalf of the ask stock
Live Crew Heather Bowen Dr Judy Reynolds
Ruth Allen Sanchez John T mccollier and
our guest Dr Joel Wallach my name is
Becca Dix thank you so much for joining
us here on askdog live go to
askdoclive.com if you have never spoken
to anybody about the youngevity products
or if you have questions and have never
spoken to anybody you can go to the
website and use the contact us option
and one of our certified holistic health
coaches will get back with you and help
you find out what nutrients are missing
to help you get on a better health
Journey
until next week and remember next week
Fridays the first Friday of the month is
ask Vet Live
and we will be taking your pet questions
bye for now bye bye bye bye everybody
love you guys love you too much bye